on Friday leaked photos reportedly
showed the set of Disney's new version
of Snow White and the Seven Dwarves
starring a Hispanic lady and a bunch of
tall guys
initially Disney told The Daily Beast
that the photos were fake
but a Disney spokesman later recanted
the denial and insisted instead that the
photos were real just not official
whatever official means they were
obviously taken on set and of course
they were real
this is all Hollywood can do now it just
remakes old stuff because it has no new
stories to tell and it does so in a way
that not only reliably erases white
people but at a deeper level than that
just doesn't make any sense
of course Snow White is brown
of course the dwarves are tall
it's 2023 up is down right is left
the next 101 Dalmatians will be played
by chihuahuas
the next Finding Nemo reboot will star a
pigeon
the next Lion King will be Coco the
gorilla
it would be bad enough if our culture
were merely absurd what's happened to
pop culture is even worse it's become
entirely predictable I'm Michael knows
this the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with my code
Knowles kwles go to goodranchers.com use
code Knowles today
Bobby Kennedy Jr making some Waves by
suggesting that kovid was a bio weapon
that was developed to Target certain
ethnicities and that spared other
ethnicities including Asians and
Ashkenazi Jews creating all sorts of
ways we'll we'll get to that in a little
bit first though
at least one generally predictable genre
has been shaken up over the last few
days the genre presidential debates and
interviews the man who shook it up
Tucker Carlson Tucker hosted a candidate
Forum in Des Moines Iowa The Blaze aired
it and it wasn't a proper presidential
debate in that he was just grilling
candidates individually
the Tucker woke up Friday morning and
Tucker chose violence and Tucker burned
down about half the GOP Presidential
field the most brutal exchange of the
day was with Mike Pence and it concerned
the war in Ukraine you are done you were
distressed that the ukrainians don't
have enough American tanks every city in
the United States has become much worse
over the past three years drive around
there's not one city that's gotten
better in the United States and it's
visible our economy has degraded the
suicide rate has jumped public filth and
disorder and crime have exponentially
increased and yet your concern is that
the ukrainians a country most people
can't find on a map who've received tens
of billions of U.S tax dollars don't
have enough tanks I think it's a fair
question to ask like where's the concern
for the United States in that well it's
not my concern
Tucker I've heard that routine from you
before but that's not my concern
I'm running for president of the United
States because I think this country is
in a lot of trouble
I think Joe Biden has weakened America
at home and abroad
and as president of the United States
we're going to restore Law and Order in
our cities we're going to secure our
border we're going to get this economy
moving again
okay
it's a terrible answer it was a terrible
answer it almost certainly destroyed
what chance there was for Mike Pence's
presidential campaign and yet
I think
Pence's critics are being a little
disingenuous here it seems clear enough
to me that Mike Pence was not actually
saying that the American interest is not
his concern I know that's what it sounds
like but if we're being charitable and
we're being honest here I don't think
that's actually what he's saying Tucker
says
well all this terrible stuff's happening
in America your concern is that Ukraine
doesn't have enough American tanks well
where's the concern for the American
interest and Mike Pence says that's not
my concern
what do you think he's referring to
there do you think he's referring to
that little bit at the end or do you
think that Mike Pence started
formulating his answer when Tucker said
your concern is that you cry doesn't
have enough American tanks and he was
planning to give this canned package to
answer which he immediately launches
into which is America's in trouble you
know he just he just goes right into the
stem speech it's obviously the latter
and yet
the result is going to be the same
it's it's not that people are dunking on
Pence here because of his his answer in
this Exchange
people are highlighting this exchange
because they already want to dunk on
pens because they already don't support
him I know the effect of that is is
identical but
he's not really saying that it's just
that people believe that his
the the uncharitable way of interpreting
his answer gets to a deeper truth
perhaps an unwitting and unconscious
truth about Pence's answer which is they
view Mike Pence
as being
a representative of this mid-2000s kind
of Republican Orthodoxy that's much more
concerned about cutting taxes at home
not really fighting the culture we're
all that hard and policing the world and
engaging in Adventures abroad fair or
unfair that's what they think that Pence
is after and Pence's answer did not do
him any service there Pence though by
the way always had a pretty much
impossible path in this presidential
race
the people who support Trump
hate him because Pence refused to hold
up the certification of the votes on
Election Day
the people who hate Trump hate Pence
because Pence made a deal with the devil
and served as the vice president for
Trump for four years so his support base
basically did not exist and he's been
trying to navigate these two Fields it
was it was not going to work and then
Tucker came in and just pulled that pin
out of the grenade threw it into the
Mike Pence presidential campaign and
fairly or unfairly completely blew it up
now
some GOP establishment types are
insisting that this Ukraine issue it's
not a big deal it's not really going to
affect the way that people vote in 2024
Americans vote on domestic policy not on
foreign policy come on get out of here
move along well this is a lot more than
just an academic question because the
war in Ukraine is heating up the Biden
Administration is becoming more
belligerent in Ukraine and now Joe Biden
is calling up reservists potentially to
fight the war in Ukraine so it's no
longer just we're going to send some
tanks and guns over there to Ukraine and
the ukrainians can defend their own
country
increasingly you're seeing the
normalization of talks that American
servicemen will be fighting against
Russians in Ukraine which strikes me as
completely insane but that's what the
Biden Administration is doing Biden just
said
just declared I'll read the exact
language
by The Authority invested in me as
president by the Constitution the laws
of the United States including sections
121 and 12 304 of title 10 U.S code I
hereby determine that it is necessary to
augment the active armed forces of the
United States for the effective conduct
of operation Atlantic resolve in and
around the United States European
command's area of responsibility that's
a lot of jargon that's a lot of
gobbledygook what does it mean it means
that we are further preparing the U.S
military to participate in something
called operation Atlantic resolve what
is Operation Atlantic resolve that
started in 2014 and it in fact I have
friends who were part of it it bolstered
the US military presence in the wake of
Russia's invasion of Crimea in 2014. so
this is during the the Obama
Administration this goes back a long
ways and so you might say well the war
in Ukraine is increasingly unpopular now
in the year of Our Lord 2023. that's
true but the war in Ukraine didn't start
a year the war in Ukraine didn't start
even two years ago the war in Ukraine
has been building and American
participation in that war has been
building for almost a decade now
2014.
this is a long time coming the CIA
director was Landing in Kiev almost a
decade ago after the color Revolution
After the maidan Revolution that kicked
out a pro-russian leader in Ukraine and
installed a more pro-western leader in
Ukraine so the the participation has
been much more long-standing than a lot
of people know and the stakes are much
higher here we're we're bought in on
Ukraine forget the bazillions of dollars
that we've given to Ukraine over the
last two years and so there is no hold
up from the dod and from the liberal
establishment to increase the the
tensions in that war that's why Tucker
Carlson is saying hey if the Democrats
already bought in on fighting in Ukraine
and half the Republicans already bought
in on that I'm going to stand up here I
want to hold people's feet to the fire
and call attention to this war before it
spins totally out of control now he
wants to restore balance to foreign
policy we need to restore balance to
nature which is why you got to check out
balance of nature right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure you
are getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day for balance
of Nature's Advanced cold vacuum process
the vitamins minerals and phytonutrients
of the fruits and veggies are preserved
so that you can get that vital nutrition
in each capsule balance of nature is a
whole food supplement with no additives
fillers extracts synthetics pesticides
or added sugar pure fruits and veggies
are the only things they put in their
capsules I love this
I love this
more I think than even these Jackal
hyenas around the daily wire who go and
they rip it all and they take it all
away when we get a delivery to the Daily
wire before even yours truly can get his
hands on any balance of nature send a
bunch of their products down here you
know how that works out with these with
these animals I got to get I got to get
there faster reap all kinds of benefits
when you check it out your body will
thank you for a limited time this summer
when you become a preferred customer
balance of nature they're throwing in a
free fruit and veggies travel set and
giving an additional 25 bucks off your
first order go to balanceofnature.com
use promo code Knolls for a free travel
set and 25 bucks off your first order as
a preferred customer balanceofnature.com
promo code Knowles
now as Biden wants to escalate the war
in Ukraine as Mike Pence gets caught
apparently seeming like he hears more
about Ukraine than the U.S even though I
think that's sort of an unfair reading
as as this becomes a major wedge issue
Donald Trump is being held out as the
guy who doesn't want war doesn't want to
increase tensions in Ukraine and yet
right now they got him Trump's Critics
on the right are pointing out that in a
recent interview with Maria Bartiromo
Trump praised Ukrainian leader Vladimir
zielinski and said that he would give
Ukraine even more weapons so you're
seeing this especially from people who
are working for either working directly
for or practically speaking working for
the DeSantis campaign among the
right-wing commentarian they're
attacking Trump and they're saying
Donald Trump wants to increase the U.S
donations of Munitions and arms and
tanks to Ukraine wants to increase that
war he's a neocon he's for a Forever War
he's for foreign adventurism and
it's just BS here is the full Exchange
you said you could end the war in
Ukraine in 24 hours yes sir how would
you do that uh I know zielinski very
well I felt he was very honorable
because when they asked him about the
perfect phone call that I made he said
it was indeed he said it was he didn't
even know what they were talking about
he could have grandstanded oh I felt
threatened well that's not going to be
enough for Putin to stop bombing no no
no I'm not saying that what I'm saying
is that I know zielinski very well and I
know Putin very well even better
and I had a good relationship very good
with both of them I would tell zelinski
no more you got to make a deal I would
tell Putin if you don't make a deal
we're going to give him a lot we're
going to give more than they ever got if
we have to I will have the deal done in
one day one day
so you see what they're doing the people
who hate Trump on the right they're only
clipping out that last part
and they're saying oh I'm going to give
zelinski more than he's ever gotten they
clip out the first part in the last part
he's a very honorable man and I'm going
to give him more than he's ever gotten
and they're going to make him sound like
he's you know Lindsey Graham 2.0 or
something but they're missing that
middle part which is the most crucial
aspect where he says I would tell
zelinski to make a deal
the reason that the war in Ukraine is
still going on is because the Biden
Administration and the liberal
establishment wants it to go on and so
they're they're not encouraging this
diplomacy at all they're bolstering this
insane idea that they're going to rat
every single Russian troop from every
part of Ukraine including Crimea it's
never going to happen
and so the liberal establishment keeps
pushing that Trump says
why does he flatter zielinski because he
wants to have influence with zielinski
says he and I got along great oh he's a
good guy and I'm going to tell him
sit down come to the table give up your
most ambitious goals sit down and make a
deal with Putin and then look I've got a
great relationship with Putin and I'm
going to tell him to come to the table
but the leverage he's going to have on
Putin is he's going to say and if Putin
won't come to the table I'm going to arm
zelinski to the hilt maybe you like
Trump maybe you hate Trump maybe you
think Trump is good at making the art of
the deal maybe you think he's a terrible
negotiator and he's just a bragger and
blow harder whatever you think about him
but it is completely disingenuous to say
that Trump is calling for an escalation
of the war in Ukraine that is the exact
opposite of what he is saying and I I
actually had forgotten that this is how
presidential primaries are
is that people tend to dig in and they
pick a candidate even among the
commentary and even among the
journalists they pick a candidate and
they decide that this is going to be my
candidate ride or die and they will
sometimes even be dishonest and
disingenuous about what the other
candidates have said and I've told you
from the beginning I think I might be
alone in the right-wing commentariat to
say I am not working for a campaign I'm
not going to endorse in a primary or at
least I'm going to do my level best not
to endorse in a primary so I'm going to
call it like I see it and if that means
that I'm going to defend Mike Pence
sometimes even if that's I'm going to do
it if that means I'm going to defend
Donald Trump sometimes I'm going to do
it if that means I'm going to defend Ron
DeSantis sometimes I'm going to do it
and all the other guys too there are a
lot more people
that uh Tucker really exposed for better
and worse which we'll get to in one
second first though speaking of Russia
I'm glad somebody listened to my CPAC
speech I'm glad that there were some
politicians in the world who were
listening to my CPAC speech which called
not just to raise the age at which you
can
[Music]
and this particular issue
the Russians have it right
and
we in America we've become so confident
in our moral superiority over those
awful evil Russians or the Chinese or
whoever that we lose sight of that
is when we become very confident in that
moral superiority
we fall into the sin of Pride which is
the queen of all Vice we just had a
month literally celebrating pride and
pride goes before destruction and a
haughty spirit before a fall
now when you want to improve your body
you're going to want to feed it good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchors.com use promo code at
Knowles you know I love anything made
with top of the line quality for me that
is good ranchers period the only thing
missing
is a pork box
and then if you ask they deliver good
ranchers has just launched their Prime
poor 100 American pork that is
Steakhouse quality this new pork box
comes with bone-in and boneless pork
chops sausage smoked brats and more plus
right now you will get 30 bucks off with
code Knowles kwles goodranchers.com on
their site
you can explore all their All-American
cuts of prime pork Prime Beef and better
than organic chicken options if you've
tried their beef and chicken before you
know how phenomenal it is you got to try
this Prime pork at least once trust me
these guys the quality is unsurpassed
and the other guys don't even come close
it's it's my favorite meal it's my
favorite meal that I can look forward to
of any regular week when I come home
what are you waiting for enjoy realmate
and real service today with good
Ranchers go to goodranchers.com use code
Knowles kwles for 30 bucks off any box
promo code Knowles Canada Wes
goodranches.com goodranches.com American
meat delivered
speaking of national humiliations Kamala
Harris
I guess I could just end it there
speaking of national humiliations Kamala
Harris she just gave a speech
in which she she
committed a gaff and a gaff most people
think a gaff is when a politician
accidentally says something that he
doesn't mean to say a gaff is actually
when a politician act accidentally tells
the truth and that's what happened here
when Kamala Harris
accidentally articulated the ultimate
goal of so many leftist policies
think about the impact on something like
public health
when we invest in clean energy and
electric vehicles and reduce population
more of our children can breathe clean
air and drink clean water
[Applause]
what was that
hold on oh I said we're gonna drink
clean air and have no no before that oh
we're gonna have clean water no hold on
I think it was after that where was the
can we play that again please think
about the impact on something like
public health
when we invest in clean energy and
electric vehicles and reduced population
okay here we go we got it we got it
reduce population
she opens up she says think about the
effect on public health
and then
as part of Public Health she suggests we
reduce the population
reducing the population means killing
people
or at the very the most charitable way
you could read that is
sterilizing people getting people not to
have kids whether physically or just
culturally
that's what they want they really do
want to reduce the population and
they've they've said it sometimes
overtly sometimes only implicitly this
has been true since Margaret Sanger in
the birth control movement
it's been true since the the most
radical forms of liberalism and it's
really been true since the Garden of
Eden because the devil and the
principalities and powers in spiritual
wickedness in high places that controls
this world really doesn't like people
and so all these left-wing policies
keep coming down to the same point which
is reducing population which is killing
human beings isn't that weird shouldn't
that make you scratch your head if
you're a liberal
you say wait all of these all of these
policies abortion the encouragement of
deviant sexual behaviors
sterilization
euthanasia so-called the Planned
Parenthood contraception on and on and
on
all for for supposedly different
purposes for women's freedom for climate
protection for compassion for the
elderly and the sick for this for that
they totally change the justification
but the end result is always the same
killing people
shouldn't that give you pause you say
hold on the Practical effect of all of
my policies is killing people no matter
what the justification is
maybe we're the baddies maybe are we
potentially the Baddies
when you look around the world and you
say wow
the vast majority of the world doesn't
kill anywhere near as many babies as we
do and they don't permit killing babies
as late in the game as we do
that and in fact the the countries with
the most radical abortion policies are
America Canada sorry to say
China and North Korea which are not
great regimes so are we are we the
baddies are we on the wrong side of this
issue Russia which is a place with all
sorts of problems that has done all
sorts of bad things
they're not
they're actually Banning that we're
promoting that are we on this particular
issue are we perhaps the baddies are we
if our motivating
drive here
is to
reduce the population
and the whole point of statecraft is so
that people can flourish it's to pursue
the good and to avoid evil and to allow
people to live happy lives which is
articulated in our
Declaration of Independence life liberty
and sometimes the classical liberals
they'll they want to rewrite the
Declaration of Independence as John
Locke articulated this phrase and
they'll say that we're here for life
liberty and property that's that's not
it that's not what Jefferson wrote
that's not what the founding fathers
wrote they said life liberty in the
pursuit of happiness which refers to a
more classical conception of statecraft
which is the common good
what is law the classical conception of
the law is that law is an ordinance of
reason for the common good by him who
has care of the community and
promulgated
it's not good to kill people it doesn't
that doesn't help people's good and
that's what they want now speaking of
killing people
speaking of Democrats making gaffes RFK
Jr just got in a lot of trouble
for a conversation that appears to have
been secretly recorded at some kind of a
donor political event
in which he discusses one theory about
covid
hundreds of millions of dollars into
ethnically targeted microbes the Chinese
have done the same thing in fact
open 19 there's no argument that it is
ethnically targeted over 19 attacks
certain races of disproportionately
the races that are most immune to
government are because of the structure
of the
genetic structure of
genetic differentials among different
races
of the um of The receptors
of the H2 receptor
um covid-19 is targeted to attack uh
Caucasians and and uh and uh black
people
the people who are most of you are
asking majors and uh and Chinese
and but at night we don't know that
whether it was deliberately targeted
that or not but there are papers out
there and then show the you know the um
the racial and ethnic differential and
impact to that that's pretty crazy huh
that's pretty wild the idea that kovid
could discriminate by race and that
kovid would most target white and black
people and the the groups that are least
susceptible to covid would be Chinese
and Ashkenazi Jews that seems totally
crazy right and as everybody was yelling
and calling RFK a kook and a nut and an
anti-semite
before I addressed any of that I thought
well let me just Google and see if any
of this is true
and then I pulled up this paper
this is a paper that was published in
BMC medicine it's a real medical journal
this is from people at the Cleveland
Clinic this is People at Columbia
University so these are serious
scientists and Scholars the headline is
new insights into genetics
susceptibility of covid-19 and Ace 2
and tmpr SS2 polymorphism analysis so
ace2 I guess that's referring to what
what Bobby Kennedy Jr was talking about
here and
then we've got we've got some numbers
here
the background here the the analysis
across the the different groups across
the different populations and it it
finds well exactly what he's talking
about it says that for uh African
Americans and for white people the risk
is much higher and for East Asians the
risk is relatively lower and for
Ashkenazi Jews the risk is uh the lowest
among any of those groups
okay
so that part is true now
there's a flip side of this I said so
hold on you're telling me that covid
doesn't affect Jews I Googled that
doesn't sound right and I find another
study that is from another medical
journal and says there's elevated Jewish
mortality from coronavirus in England
and Wales in epidemiological and
demographic detective story so
you got the one study it says because of
this H2 receptor whatever the hell it is
uh you've got very low Jewish Ashkenazi
Jewish susceptibility of the virus and
then this other study it says you've got
elevated mortality so what does this
mean
how the hell should I know I majored in
history and Italian literature I don't
know what an ace2 receptor is I don't
even really believe scientific studies
I don't do I think that uh Bobby Kennedy
Jr hates the Jews or Chinese I don't
know why they didn't say it was wasn't
anti-chinese racist or something like
that but I don't know does he do I think
that no I don't really think that is
sort of an eccentric guy
you know what I do think though the only
thing I can conclude from this whole
episode
is I don't know anything about
the covid science or whatever you know
the main takeaway here for me is that
the media are going to treat Bobby
Kennedy Jr as a Republican
because this whole episode has nothing
to do with the papers the people who are
calling him a complete maniac and a
racist and to this and that they don't
even point out he's referring to a real
scientific study that's been out for a
few years they don't engage in that
study they're not raising studies that
might perhaps question those results it
has nothing to do with that at all they
don't care what he said they're just
going to call him a racist because
that's what the libs do to conservatives
when conservatives are in public life so
Bobby Kennedy Jr who is a Kennedy who's
from the most prominent Democrat family
in the country right now because he is
questioning the liberal establishment
because he's going up against Biden in
this presidential race he is going to be
treated as a Republican
he is going to be treated as a
conservative
he's going to be a racist doesn't matter
what he says
doesn't matter what he means doesn't
matter what studies he cites
the covet stuff doesn't even matter
increasingly this guy he could talk
about tax policy he could talk about
Ukraine he could talk about anything
they will treat him that way and it will
probably work right now Bobby Kennedy
seems to have maxed out his support at
17 to 19 hard to imagine that the The
Establishment lets him get any higher
than that now speaking of the 2024
election
CNN is reporting
that Joe Biden is not actually running
for re-election CNN reports that top
Democrats and donors have reached out to
quote possible replacements for Joe
Biden and had conversations about them
getting in the race as Joe Biden
struggles for the White House
what does this mean this is a I had the
same reaction to the CNN report as I had
to the viral moment of Bobby Kennedy
talking about genetic susceptibility to
the Coronavirus
which is the story is not the story
itself the story is the way that it's
playing out in the media
do I I don't trust CNN on anything so do
I trust that Biden's not running no I
think Biden probably does want to run
for president I don't trust that report
what I what I doubt now know from the
CNN story is that top Democrats and the
media and the liberal establishment do
not want Biden to run and the reason
they don't want Biden to run is not
because he's extremely old and
incompetent and has wind blowing through
his ears that's been true for 50 years
of Joe Biden's politics at least the
fact that he wasn't always the sharpest
tool in the shed and they already knew
that he was elderly when he ran the
first time that's not it the reason that
they don't want him to run for
re-election is because right now he's
probably going to lose
at least if the election is fair at
least there's a good shot that he loses
and what does that mean that means that
contrary to what you've been hearing
from a lot of the media reports that
there's no way that Donald Trump could
ever possibly beat Joe Biden the liberal
media clearly think that Donald Trump
could beat Joe Biden because right now
Donald Trump is overwhelmingly likely to
get the GOP nomination so if they felt
that Biden could beat Trump walk away
with it then they would make Biden the
nominee and then he would quietly go off
into the sunset after he won re-election
I suspect they also think that Ron
DeSantis could be Joe Biden but my
takeaway here is they fear that the
likely GOP nominee the one who's up 30
points in the polls Donald Trump could
beat Biden and I think that he could
probably beat him
too
and when Dr Jordan B Peterson
made the decision to join daily wire
plus it was a major win for those who
championed free speech and intellectual
debate with one year of unparalleled
output his contributions have set new
standards and remained unmatched by any
other platform daily wire plus now as a
vast array of exclusive Jordan Peterson
content offering hundreds of hours of
captivating content you won't find
anywhere else Jordan has created
thought-provoking works that reshape
your perspective on life which include
vision and Destiny marriage and Dragons
monsters and men Additionally you can
immerse yourself in discussions that
nurture your spiritual side such as
law across and literacy and Jordan's
groundbreaking Series in the book of
Exodus that's only the beginning I have
not even mentioned that his Beyond order
lecture series or his extensive Archive
of lectures and podcasts this is the
compendium of all things Jordan plus
there's even more new exclusive content
on the horizon it's only the beginning
by becoming a daily wire plus member you
will embark on an unforgettable
experience that will fuel your thirst
for knowledge and Inspire personal
growth like never before go to daily
wire.com subscribe to become a member
today
my favorite comment yesterday is from
raider Batman
who says the Secret Service is staying
true to its name they're keeping
everything they find a secret so true
including an especially fingerprints on
dime bags of the old Colombian nose
candy found in The West Wing
speaking of presidential politics back
to that candidate forum
Tucker
really did a number on Mike Pence he may
have
gone even harder on a candidate polling
even lower that would be former Arkansas
governor ASA Hutchinson
[Music]
what do you want to talk about you want
to talk about marginal corporate tax
cuts ASA I think everyone in this room
realizes this is an important issue
and Asa has nothing and he just sputters
this is what happens when you hire
managers there are two kinds of
Republicans one increasingly sees there
are
conservatives who are offering an
alternative vision for our country and
what it what good looks like and what
flourishing life looks like and then
there are managers there are people who
are going to manage liberalism in a
slightly more efficient way
and ASA Hutchinson is in the latter
category he's saying yeah look I agree
with the Liberals on everything I defer
to the scientists and the technocrats
and the the leading liberals on
everything but I'm just going to do in a
way that's a little bit more efficient
and polite
oh okay cool wow boy let's go where do I
sign up it's so
stirs my soul so much the other
candidate who
did not fare terribly well
from this grilling by Tucker
Senator Tim Scott
stop this war and reach a piece as as
one does where both sides you know
concede some of their interests like why
wouldn't that be in our interest to do
that I think the faster we get the peace
the better off we are what we don't want
to do from my perspective is allow
ourselves to ask for a premature peace
that cannot be achieved as the alliances
continue to come together to the extent
that we can find our path out of this
situation the better off we are so
what's the point at which we'll know
that we've achieved our goal just and I
say that within the context of having
watched 20 years of occupation in
Afghanistan where nobody could answer
the question what's the point and no one
in Congress ever asked that question
amazingly so what is the what is the
specific goal here yeah so I would say
that the objective should be for
salinsky and Ukraine to be able to
achieve Victory by maintaining as much
of their territory as they possibly can
and then seeing the resources that we've
deployed along with our Western
alliances
achieving the peace that I believe comes
when you get these two folks to sit down
and have a conversation that allows them
to determine where those lines will be
drawn for the next hundred years okay
Tucker just lets it go okay but Tim
Scott didn't say anything there
he did his best and he's a nice guy but
he didn't say anything he said I want
peace but we need we we shouldn't
achieve a piece before we can have a
peace that is achievable
and Tucker presses him and says well
what's that look like
when do we know we've achieved the peace
that is achievable he says well it's
when these guys Putin and and so let's
see when they sit down and they have a
conversation
okay what's the point of the
conversation well the point of
conversation is going to be they're
going to work out what the limits are
yeah right that's the question what are
the limits what what is it what is the
okay check check we've got our we've
accomplished our goals now the war is
over well he says it a little bit
earlier in the answer he says well it's
when zelinski can keep as much of his
land as he possibly can okay well as
much of his land as he possibly can keep
is all of it
so now you're saying that the war is
going to continue until Ukraine
maintains its territorial integrity
that it had before what two years ago
that it had before 2014 that it had
before the invasion of Crimea that it
had
that's never going to happen this is a
thousand year territorial dispute that
we're talking about in Ukraine so Tim
Scott's answer effectively is we're
going to have War forever which was the
which was the answer in Afghanistan but
the the imperialists who supported that
didn't have the courage of their
convictions to actually say it
maintaining an overseas Empire is a
common theme throughout history and it's
a defensible position might not be your
position might not be my position it's a
defensible one but the people who were
arguing for that
couldn't really make the argument they
didn't want to make the argument because
when when you ask these imperialists
when you ask these foreign adventurists
what is the goal of this war
the answer is the goal is to keep it
going
and what the more conservative people
are saying right now lowercase C
conservative they're saying well you
know
when you're just engaged in an
open-ended war with a nuclear former
superpower where you're encroaching on a
buffer state that previously separated
you two guys who were it out on the
brink of nuclear war for the back half
of the 20th century closest we've ever
come to an all-out nuclear war
that gets pretty
dangerous and no one except for like one
guy at a Canada Forum no one seems to
want to press the candidates on that
question as we all Sleepwalk into world
war three
you know the rest of the show continues
now on that happy note you don't want to
miss it become a member use code Knowles
kwles check out for two months free on
all annual plans it's music Monday baby
we'll see you at the member block
[Music]
oh